they do it Makarova khatola put put  kadai Yoli Hey portulaca friend and a  Matisse Picasso Dada booyah bear story  dobry lost Oreo and Patos collar  brolo richard williams and image a son  Sanjay's super team Sanjay Patel and  Miko Grindle  we can't live without cosmos Konstantin  runs eight World of Tomorrow Don  Hertzfeld their story  Gabriele Osorio and Pato Escala this is  the first house for a denomination  sorry oh I'm hot to ask Allah  Wow we are really happy right now we  want to thank the Academy our families  and everywhere in Chile that have  supported us and trust in our work  personally I want to dedicate this  achievement to my grandfather who is the  one who inspire this story and to all  the people like him who had suffer in  exile we really hope that this must  never happen again  Thanks thank you all we are from a small  country called Chile this is the first  Oscar for country so this is very  important for us thank you all  I'm gonna develop all via DNA